[Music]
traditional hasidic music is based on
words of prayer it has a certain sadness
to it
but my music is different instead of
searching google i'm busy making google
hangouts
was the first one with the whole hasidic
outfit that comes from a very
close-minded community who went to do
crazy shows with crazy outfits
i've been called acidic lady gaga i've
been called the jewish elvis but i
promise you i would rather be just
leaper
this is the house i grew up
12 children in this house
i was born in a new square a religious
orthodox very close-minded community we
had no radio no television there's only
one rabbi one synagogue one girls school
one boy school
i barely left the community i was having
a hard time as a child and traditional
hasidic music was something that gave me
an outlook
i only did prosthetic music originally
so i started to perform only at weddings
that was my dream to be a wedding singer
i had to be 21 years old when i heard my
first non-jewish song i started working
for the butcher and the fish store so i
put the radio on and i think the first
song was i need to know i need to know
tell me baby girl cause i need to know
and that opened up a whole world to me
[Music]
listening to sexual music i had a chance
to discover there's a different way of
composing lyrics and composing music so
when i started writing lyrics the lyrics
that i used were new
my music was advancing towards hip-hop r
b
and american mother music
my music has
had many reactions throughout the years
many rabbis try to stop me
everything that's new can make some
people who live in a fanatic system can
make them mad but many good people even
rabbis love me and they recognize that
this is god-given talent and they don't
let me stop
i was privileged to perform in crazy
places i did one show even with jay leno
i did the medicine carton i've made
music videos that have millions of views
i've recorded probably 19 albums or so
i'm never stopping until god will say
leapfrog is done
i had many times i was thinking to drop
out completely from the kassidi
community just run away but this is
where i was born this is where my
heritage is this is where my upbringing
is
and it's a smarter move to take this and
modernize it i try to take khasidam and
open it up it's a beautiful thing to
open the mind
and think
[Music]
you